welcome to the michael knowles show i
should say welcome back to the michael
knowles show i know that i'm just
starting the show but i am starting the
show for the second time today
and and i am starting the show i've
already got a show that went out it's
already out there in your rss feeds but
i'm doing the show again because just
after my show went out
i get on an airplane i had a wonderful
night last night i was with the young
americas foundation in santa barbara
lots of great young conservatives i was
feeling energized about the country
we do the show talk about all these
great supreme court decisions that have
been coming out this term and just i'm
getting on the plane that the
show airs we get this news
roe versus wade
planned parenthood v casey
two of the worst decisions ever made in
the history of the united states in in
the case of roe probably the single
worst supreme court decision ever
led to the deaths of 63 million babies
in the united states since 1973 those
two egregiously hideously
constitutionally absurd morally insane
cases
overruled
dobbs versus jackson women's health
organization i said when this happened
i'm on the airplane i see this i tell
the team we're doing another show today
get ready we're doing another one
this is the most
surprising
and i would have to say the best
political event to occur in this country
in my lifetime remember this date
june
24th 2022
one of the most important
dates
in american history
so the the decision comes out
i'm getting ready i say i've got a
little bit of time before i go to the
studio i'm going to read this decision i
assume most of you you've been at work
all day you probably haven't timed
haven't had time to read through this uh
213-page decision but i think i can sum
up this 213-page decision
in about 30 seconds to a minute here's
what happened you get
the decision of the court six to three
rules to uphold the mississippi pro-life
law
that brought this to to the supreme
court in the first place so you get the
conservatives
and you get john roberts john roberts
the chief justice he's a swing vote he's
supposed to be a conservative but he's
pretty squishy so you get alito you get
thomas
you get kavanaugh you get barrett you
get gorsuch you get chief justice
roberts vote to uphold the mississippi
law then the three libs say they're not
going to uphold the law but the decision
that everyone's talking about is not the
6-3 decision it's a 5-4 decision
because five justices it's the
conservatives no roberts vote
to go further than just upholding the
mississippi law they vote to overrule
roe v wade and planned parenthood casey
so here's what they say the court
majority
written by sam alito basically identical
to that leaked draft that we saw some
weeks ago
they say the mississippi law is legit
and the planned parenthood v casey
and roe v wade are not legit
done
then the libs scream and they say but we
really want abortion
then chief justice roberts says in his
own opinion he says hey guys look can we
please just not deal with the whole roe
v wade thing right now can we maybe take
that up at a later date we don't let's
not talk about that
then the court majority says nope sorry
chief justice roberts we are talking
about that then enters brett kavanaugh
in his own concurring opinion and he
says yep i totally agree with the court
majority but i want to be really really
clear here the court has basically
nothing to say about abortion
one of the briefs that was submitted to
the court when this case was being
heard
was written by robbie george and john
finis these are two conservative legal
scholars who argued that
actually not only
should the court
overturn roe v wade and send the issue
of abortion back to the states but
actually the court should overrule roe v
wade and outlaw abortion nationwide so
don't make it just an issue for the
legislators actually go in and and we
say we the justices are going to outlaw
abortion throughout the united states
because of the 14th amendment because of
equal protection under the law
kavanaugh's opinion that he filed
separately
says no that's not correct we reject
that view this is only about submitting
the issue back to the states
then the justices whine some more and
they say no no
brett kavanaugh you're you're
downplaying this this isn't really a
modest decision this isn't really a
narrow limited decision
the the decision here in dobbs is going
to imperil all sorts of other issues
and it's really interesting the way that
the liberals argued this they they
didn't have a good argument as to where
the constitutional right to an abortion
shows up in the document because it's
just not there because it was made up it
was a preposterous opinion at the time
and the honest left-wing legal scholars
even the ones who support legal abortion
have admitted that since then
well yes we want abortion maybe we
should even uphold roe because it's been
on the books a long time
but it's not a well-argued case
frankly even planned parenthood v casey
which reaffirmed the quote-unquote right
to an abortion actually overruled parts
of roe v wade because roe v wade was a
ridiculous decision so the libs are
arguing here with kavanaugh and with the
majority on the court and they're saying
you're downplaying this you're saying
this is really narrowly tailored and and
we're not going to really make a good
argument for abortion here but we're
going to scare all the other americans
and say well if we allow the court to
overrule roe v wade they might overrule
the griswold case the griswold case
which found a constitutional right to
condoms this might overrule lawrence v
texas which found a constitutional right
to gay sex this might overrule
obergefell the hodges which found a
brand new definition of marriage that
has never existed anywhere in all of
human history until anthony kennedy the
romantic poet of the supreme court
decided to find one somewhere in the
emanations and the penumbras and
whatever bottom of the bong he was
smoking at that time and so that was the
argument from the liberals they said
look guys even if you don't think the
abortion argument is very strong what
about all these other things the
conservatives are coming for your
condoms and your gay stuff and the
majority on the court
said no we're not doing that at all
but then in comes clarence thomas and
clarence thomas has his own concurring
opinion and he says yeah well but
actually
maybe we should come for those things
and and it's frankly the most
interesting part of this
opinion
the most interesting part of this ruling
is that clarence thomas concurring
opinion because it's the most ambitious
it goes the furthest
it doesn't say we're just going to stop
here with roe v wade with planned
parenthood because he's sending abortion
back to the states it says no we're
going to undo a whole lot of other
liberal juris prudence clarence thomas
wanted to go further there was this
question
when the leaked draft came out and the
draft was written by sam alito a lot of
conservatives were wondering hey wait a
second why isn't clarence thomas the one
writing this opinion
we know that clarence thomas hates roe
and casey we know that clarence thomas
hates abortion he's the senior most
judge on the court so why isn't he the
one writing it
now we see why
because clarence thomas wanted to go
further than the court did
clarence thomas
took issue with what is called
substantive due process
substantive due process is this
invention by liberals on the court to
find a constitutional right to all sorts
of things that they want that don't
actually appear in the constitution
and so
you you have an interesting little
contradiction here from some of the
conservatives which is
the liberals have no argument whatsoever
to defend abortion in the constitution
so they're they're just fear-mongering
about all these other stupid court
decisions that they think that people
like and they think uh will scare people
into voting for democrats in the
midterms then you've got some
conservative legal scholars and some
conservatives on the court saying no
those things aren't threatened at all
but then you've got clarence thomas who
i think is making the more honest
argument and he's saying no those things
actually probably should be threatened
you're right they're not threatened in
this opinion of the court
but perhaps they should be
and of course they should be
in in something like griswold the
griswold case
the court finds a constitutional right
to condoms
maybe you like condoms maybe you think
condoms should be legal i strongly
suspect that the vast majority of
americans if asked their opinion on
condoms would would vote to have legal
condoms
but does anyone really believe condoms
are in the constitution show me the
condom clause of the constitution i
don't i don't see it
listen i didn't go to a fancy law school
but i just don't see it
how about
gay sexual behavior
lawrence v texas discovers a
constitutional right to gay sexual
behavior
gay sexual behavior has broadly been
tolerated throughout most of american
history it's been against the law in
certain parts of the country and those
laws have remained on the books though
they rarely were enforced
and maybe you think that
gay sexual behavior is totally fine
maybe you think homosexual sodomy
totally if defined thing i bet if you
put it up to a vote with the vast
majority of americans they'd vote to
have it be legal
where is the sodomy clause of the
constitution
can you find it for me do i need to get
a magnifying glass out to look just
beneath the emanations and just over the
penumbras of the special mystery of life
closes because i don't see it it's just
not there how about obergefell are you
seriously going to tell me that the
framers of the constitution
believed that they were redefining
marriage to
to to an extent that had never been
probably even imagined in human history
to say that sexual difference has
nothing to do with marriage
and then that that true definition of
marriage that marriage can be between a
man and a woman or a man and a man or a
woman and a woman
that that just lay dormant
lay hidden for all of american history
until about seven or eight years ago
when anthony kennedy
in his insight and wisdom discovered it
there you're really going to tell me
that
if you put it up for a vote today i
don't know what would happen actually on
marriage
every time
that gay marriage quote-unquote was put
up for a vote
it was shot down even in california it
was shot down
so i don't know if you put it up for a
vote maybe it wouldn't get shut down but
today i suspect it probably would be it
would be upheld but regardless of your
views on marriage
show me that definition in the
constitution
you're not going to find that there and
so the liberals do have a point the
liberals do have a point
they have
wielded the courts to push radical
policies for at least 50 years now i
guess much more than that probably
probably more like 70 years
and they have perverted our
jurisprudence they have destroyed the
integrity of the court they've made our
politics coarser
more dangerous more violent
less democratic for for that matter it's
very funny to me that the people who
wrapped themselves in the mantle of
democracy are are the ones protesting
right now and trying to dox the justices
and screaming their heads off outside
the supreme court whatever you think
about abortion this decision dobbs
versus jackson women's health
organization is one of the most
pro-democracy decisions ever it might be
the single most pro-democracy decision
ever in the history of the united states
it takes a matter that the courts the
nine robed lawyers on the supreme court
had taken away from the people to decide
and returns it to the people to decide
that's pro-democracy
and yet the alleged pro-democracy crowd
the ones who shriek and scream and
clutch their pearls about our sacred
wonderful democracy they're the ones who
oppose it we have a whole lot to say
obviously about this decision itself you
almost couldn't wish for a better
decision given the political realities
that we are living in right now just an
absolutely magnificent ruling we have to
talk about the politics of this of
course as well it's not just about it's
primarily about bioethics and these
babies that are now going to live
because of the courage of these justices
and and frankly the courage of mitch
mcconnell and the courage of donald
trump and and the political ability of
them to get all of this through and the
courage of people to vote for these guys
and stand up and and really fight back
in our political order
that's that's the most important thing
then there's of course the legal
question the constitutional question
then there's a political question what
does this mean we are in an election
year right now we are in the heat of the
midterm elections what is this historic
rolling ruling going to mean for
november here to help me discuss is the
great molly hemingway editor-in-chief of
the federalist
senior journalism fellow at hillsdale
and a fox news contributor molly thank
you for being here
it is great to be here with you michael
it is truly great this ruling came out
when i was on an airplane
i haven't slept probably in a week i've
been on the road doing all sorts of we'd
already put my show out today i said i
don't care get me some coffee clear the
schedule this might be
well not might be this is the greatest
day
for american politics in my lifetime
it is easily the greatest day for so
many people who survived this regime of
roe v wade most of us were born after it
was implemented you know that we
survived is a wonderful gift first off
but it also speaks to how much work
went into this from so many different
people you know the conservative
judicial movement
the people who decided to focus on
electing senators who would who would
approve good nominees the desi the the
decision to actually support donald
trump which wasn't easy for a lot of
people and the pro-life movement got
behind him when he said he would
nominate good justices and he did and
you know the people who voted for him
and it's just a major day of vindication
there was a lot of failure leading up to
this moment a lot of failures by
republican presidents but this
finally succeeded um this this approach
and it's really impressive and a lot of
people that you have to thank for it
there are and that's especially true of
the conservative legal movement and it's
especially true of trump past republican
presidents have always been a mixed bag
at best when it comes to the judges and
then in walks donald trump and everyone
says the guy's a big buffoon he's a
total rube he doesn't know anything
about politics there's no way that he's
going to give us the sort of victories
that we want especially this one the
kind of holy grail of a of a
constitutional case and then trump is
three
for three and that's the margin of
victory there uh donald trump obviously
has already come out and said promises
made promises kept we did it guys
wonderful decision molly how do you
think this plays politically in november
what's interesting because even as
recently as maybe 12 years ago this was
the type of issue that democrats would
use to really orchestrate a media
hysteria campaign
we saw that in what was called the war
on women it was an actual democrat plot
to turn colorado blue and other states
but something has changed in that
meantime one the country has gotten even
more pro-life than it was before and
this decision is frankly very moderate
it's not banning abortion even as much
as pro-life people would love for there
to be a protection of all human life it
is pretty much where the american people
are which is they generally oppose
abortion but also generally want it
legal at some point and that's that's
what this type of ruling allows but
there's also the failure of the media
they became such propagandists that no
longer are they able to run this type of
hysteria campaign and propaganda
campaign with the same effect and so
democrats really tried to make this an
issue last year in virginia in the
gubernatorial race they it was basically
an abortion race that they tried to make
it you might remember glenn younkin won
despite the democrats trying to make
that the signal signature issue
so
do you have any sense moving from the
politics of the ballot box in november
to the politics of the court
why did the chief justice not go all the
way here he had a 6-3 ruling on the
mississippi pro-life law clear his day
upholding the law but then roberts won't
go all the way in in roberts's opinion
he says look guys uh i'm fine with the
pro-life law but can't we kind of punt
this rov roe v weight issue down the
road do we really have to deal with this
now and the court says yes we do so it
ends up being a 5-4 decision on
overruling row what was the argument
here if the argument was to uphold the
integrity of the court wouldn't a 6-3
decision
do much much more good for the integrity
of the court than than this kind of
confusing breakdown we have now
so i first want to mention that i wrote
with kerry severino a book on the
kavanaugh confirmation the excellent
book on the kavanaugh
confirmation thank you and it kind of
gets into some of these discussions
about what roberts was doing and how
he's you know ruled in different cases
um
i don't think he makes a lot of sense
here i mean
one of the things that's interesting
about alito's opinion here or decision
today he talks about how they tried to
rescue roe which everyone agrees with
just like the worst legal decision in
the history of the court um by sort of
rewriting it in casey and they thought
that maybe it would make it so that it
wouldn't be such a contentious issue and
of course all that happened was their
new standards of how to handle abortion
jurisprudence just led to even more
cases more confusion right and so
roberts today says oh he's fine with the
dobbs he's fine with dobbs he's fine
with um the state limiting abortion in
mississippi he just doesn't want to get
rid of roe or like this idea that you
could somehow come up with some new test
that would make the court into this
legislature and it just doesn't really
make sense it doesn't make sense
unfortunately for
roberts unfortunately for the liberals
fortunately for justice and the american
jurisprudential
tradition and the constitution and the
babies it doesn't make sense and those
those cases collapsed under the weight
of their own incoherence and because of
the courage of these conservatives molly
thank you so much for being here molly
hemingway everyone go follow her she's
so wonderful i didn't expect it to
happen
i've never expected it to happen in my
life
i even after that draft was leaked
the alito draft that said they would
overrule it i still didn't really
believe that it would happen that's
how
significant this ruling
is to help me to help me parse what it
all means to help me make some sense of
it is my friend ryan t anderson
the president of the ethics and public
policy center in washington dc and the
author of the greatest titled book in
the history of publishing when harry
became sally responding to the
transgender moment as well as a number
of other books and publications ryan
thank you so much for coming on the show
thanks for having me today's a great day
to be an american today is a truly great
day to be an american i
am on an airplane when the ruling comes
out i immediately download the ruling
it's 213 pages i say okay well i got a
long flight so let's go through it
did the conservatives seem a little
split here you've got robert saying he's
going to uphold the pro-life law but not
go for roe you've got kavanaugh saying
he doesn't want the court to really say
anything about abortion and just leave
this to the legislatures you've got the
majority of the court the five justices
saying that they're going to overrule
roe and casey but this isn't going to
affect other cases and then you've got
my man clarence thomas with a concurring
he's and he's telling it like it is and
and what the biggest argument from the
liberals as far as i could tell is hey
look never mind this rose stuff we we
love abortion we want ro to remain but
really the scary part is they're coming
for your condoms they're coming for your
gay rights and
marriage and things like that and the
majority of of the court seems to say no
that's not true but then i'm reading the
thomas concurring opinion and he seems
to say yeah okay maybe that's true
what's your take
all right so um
i think the first thing we should do is
we should celebrate that row and casey
are no longer the law of the land right
i mean lo roe and casey are no longer
binding precedent on lower courts and
therefore they're not going to be used
to prevent states and for that matter
the federal government uh from enacting
laws that protect unborn babies and that
protect their mothers from the violence
of abortion i mean as we're speaking
several states are enforcing their
pro-life laws that previously they were
prevented from enforcing and so
you said you never thought you would
actually see this day so i mean i think
the initial reaction has to be one of
like praise god it finally happened yeah
49 years too late i mean they should
have admitted they made a mistake
at the first opportunity they shouldn't
have taken this long um but you know my
thought is one of gratitude to the
people who didn't give up who didn't
lose hope it would have been easy
especially after the disaster of planned
parenthood v casey for pro-lifers to
just be despondent to despair
and i think a lot of people played the
long game um they worked through the
system non-violently i mean it's unlike
what we're seeing with jane's revenge
tonight unlike what we've seen with the
firebombing of pregnancy resource
clinics people who worked through the
process they won elections they got
presidents to commit to appointing
constitutionalists to the bench
and then they brought the case and they
argued the case and they made the case
and we won and we should celebrate that
so i mean that's my initial reaction we
had a we had five justices say row and
casey are no more
um
look kavanaugh's concurrence is not um
something i particularly uh appreciate
um i think he should have just not
written anything um and just signed onto
the elito and period but i mean he seems
to be signaling that he's not
that he has no appetite for the 14th
amendment personhood argument for
example you know something that you know
two scholars that i've learned you know
a great deal from john finis at oxford
and robbie george at princeton you know
they make the argument that on the
original understanding the 14th
amendment no person can be denied equal
protection of the law they're not
talking about peter singer people
they're talking about flesh and blood
human beings and
the entity in the womb is a human being
it's a person and a state can't deny it
equal protection of the law i mean that
kavanaugh's signaling that he's not
going to entertain that argument um
which means that you know for at least
the near future i can't count to five on
that argument uh which means you and i
and our listeners need to persuade our
neighbors to get our elected
representatives to pass laws uh
protecting people from the violence of
abortion we have to get to work now the
ball's in our court so to speak so in in
a way you're actually giving me a little
more
respect for kavanaugh in a kind of
backhanded way which is
kavanaugh writes and i had the same
reaction you did i thought why is he
even writing this this is so this is so
silly but oh he's writing it to signal
don't bring this case don't bring the
14th amendment robbie george john finnis
personhood case it's not going anywhere
at least not right now i mean so yeah
you know i don't my guess would be that
um alito thomas and gorsuch
um
might be more open to that than not i
don't know where barrett would come down
uh the chief and kavanaugh would
probably not have an appetite for it um
but that means it's something that as
we're vetting justice you know nominees
for the next uh conservative
presidential administration this can be
one of the things that we're looking for
you know who who filed amicus briefs who
who's embraced the legal theories that
we're going to want to see
vindicated but in the meantime
at the very least section 5 of the 14th
amendment says congress has the
authority to enact legislation
to protect the rights that the other
sections of uh the 14th amendment
articulate so there's a role for the
federal government for congress to pass
laws protecting babies there's a role
for all 50 states
and that's where the more immediate
protections are going to come from um so
you're now what in tennessee i guess
right you need to be working to see your
state uh enact pro-life laws i'm in
virginia uh our governor uh governor
younkin announced today that he's in
favor of a 15-week law that's not good
enough but it's better than what we
currently have right i mean 15 weeks
just gets us to where europe is i mean
to give you an idea like it's not even
the mississippi law was a 15-week law
and it's like i think 42 out of the 47
european nations have laws at least that
protective if not more protective so
there's a lot of work to be done this is
something that americans even american
conservatives i think fail to appreciate
the the radicalism and the barbarity of
the american abortion regime
the the mississippi law puts us on par
with france france the france these are
people that chop off the heads of their
own citizens and decapitate kings and
queens
they're the people who invented the term
left in political discourse and and they
look at americans and they say oh my
gosh what are you doing to these babies
so obviously there's there's a lot of
work to be done
what did you make of the clarence thomas
concurrence
i think um
thomas and uh back when scalia were was
on the bench they would frequently be
writing dissents
um to educate the next generation and to
educate law students like so they
thought they were in the truth-telling
business and even though they kept being
outvoted because at the time you know
they didn't have enough colleagues who
were right thinking they were going to
tell the truth in their descents to
educate that next generation of law
student who is now
you know on the court amy cody barrett
you know clerk for scalia came of age
reading the scalia descents now she's
part of the majority and i think thomas
is doing something similar with now his
concurrences right this you know in a
different era he would have been writing
that opinion as a dissent today he's
writing it as a concurrence because he
agrees with the bottom line we're
overturning roe we're overturning casey
he's also pointing out but the way that
we did this was by operating within the
framework of existing kind of 14th
amendment jurisprudence on so-called
substantive due process he points out
that's an oxymoronic term due process is
a process substantive protections or
substantives there's not a substantive
due process um the court just made stuff
up
um alito did what he had to do to get
five votes right and so you know thomas
didn't get anyone to join his
concurrence which you know shows you you
know where where people are on the court
right now alito wrote what he had to
wrote and um he wrote what he had to
write in order to get five votes and i
think that's you know working within
settled kind of for the moment
jurisprudence to get to the right
outcome that's what you have to do to be
prudent to be a statesman and we should
share that they were intimidated that
kavanaugh had a death threat of you know
an active assassination attempt they
could have caved um roberts couldn't get
anyone to join him in his middle
position right that roberts didn't
concur he occurred in the in the uh um
concurred in the judgment but not
actually in the opinion you might say
ryan that he he tried to
split the baby i'll see myself out yeah
yeah
yes uh you're the host so i can't you
know come out with the hook and get rid
of you but
yeah i mean he wanted to say let's just
uphold the mississippi law but not
overturn rowan casey and you know what
with the majority points out and the
response to that is that this means that
next year we'll be back with another
case because we're going to have a
10-week case or an eight-week case or
texas six-week case like why not just
once and for all admit we got it wrong
than doing this piecemeal
so i i don't see any um prudence in what
roberts wrote as his um concurring in
the judgment
opinion
um it did leave me scratching my head
it did leave me because i i felt it
wasn't persuasive it didn't make a lot
of sense and i felt it didn't even do
that thing that roberts is always so
concerned with doing which is protecting
the integrity and stability of the court
i thought really in in many ways
leaving the overruling of roe as a 5-4
decision it kind of undercut that so i i
don't really know what he was thinking i
share your bemusement at his uh opinion
what do you make of the the liberals i i
tried to read the liberals dissent as
charitably as i could and i i thought it
was embarrassing and particularly
compared to
alito's opinion of the court and
thomas's concurrence i thought it was it
was just frivolous and a sort of silly
descent
i mean
you would call it sophomoric but i think
that would be an insult to sophomores i
mean this is this is like literally
um we're just going to repeat a bunch of
mantras that you know liberal jurists
have been telling ourselves for 50 years
without actually addressing any of the
arguments that the other side has been
advancing
and so anyone who knows um anything
about this area of the law anyone who's
read alito's opinion
and then you read the dissent you're
like we're just living in different
universes
you're not actually talking about the
constitution you're just keeping you
keep citing other court rulings
then that's justification for this you
know so this bad court ruling plus that
bad court ruling plus that bad court
ruling justifies this other bad court
ruling um
and then nowhere do they wrestle with
the question of
you know what's the competing interest
here they talk about women on female
autonomy they talk about liberty they
talk about privacy
what value does the child who is killed
has
right what value i mean what value are
you assigning there and how do you think
it is that you as judges or the
constitution as a document
settles that balancing
um and this is kavanaugh's point where
he says look i just think the
constitution's silent on this i mean
that's a more respectable position
than uh the argument of the three
dissenters where it's just that you know
these vague notions of um privacy and
autonomy uh somehow justify lethal
violence
in the womb
i can't help but notice
that uh joe biden
the the currently sitting president i'll
tell you maybe he's been a crypto
conservative all along his catholicism
is coming out wittingly or unwittingly
as sort of a providential that the
second catholic president manages to
preside over the overruling of roe v
wade
although he was fighting against a tooth
and nail but because joe biden doesn't
really believe in anything and he just
kind of blows blows with the political
winds in 1982
joe biden proposed a constitutional
amendment that would have done exactly
what this court ruling today
did and yet now he comes out against the
ruling how does one make sense of that
um
political opportunism um that people
have you know put their eternal soul at
risk for the sake of winning an election
which is just really sad i mean i i
think
you know in the book that alexandra and
i have coming out on abortion we have a
chapter on how
abortions corrupted our political
parties and we just go through kind of
chapter and verse
all these pro-life democrats
who as they grew in office discovered
they were more willing to be an elected
democrat than being pro-life
um catholic democrats used to be a thing
pro-life democrats used to be think now
they're endangered species
and
you you have to ask yourself like for
what especially as some of these elected
officials are nearing the end of life
um you know you pray that they have a
death bed conversion because it's um
it's just when you ask you how do you
make sense of it um it's just really
tragic it is true it's tragic and
empathetic it tragic for the political
process and and tragic for them you
think what you so you've you've thrown
away your principles you your beliefs
hundreds of thousands of babies per year
upwards of a million and possibly your
souls
for what for what for what especially
now when you have there's such a major
victory for life ryan uh have to leave
it there everyone go find ryan t
anderson all over the interwebs and the
social medias uh ryan thank you so much
for coming on
sure thank you
remember that date june 24th
2022
dobbs versus jackson women's health
organization
already etched in history already we can
know this already today that this will
be regarded as one of the most important
decisions in the history of the united
states supreme court
and i think it's really important to
thank two people
so we should thank many many people i
mean there are there are too many people
to name all of the activists who have
worked tirelessly often behind the
scenes for years in the pro-life
movement
who have not been discouraged starting
in 1973 with the huge gut punch of
planned parenthood v casey
in the early 90s
and on and on and on
they've continued to work tirelessly
obviously the courage of the justices
these are justices
who at this very moment are having their
lives threatened by wackos and lunatics
and left-wing political activists but i
repeat myself there are people passing
out palm cards right now with the
personal home addresses of the
conservative judges
this is really dangerous someone tried
to assassinate brett kavanaugh
i know that disappeared from the news
and so you probably haven't heard about
that if you've been listening to shows
other than this one and a handful of
other conservative shows there have been
threats against alito against amy
barrett
against
kavanaugh and the rest of them but the
two people that we really have to thank
are mitch mcconnell why mitch mcconnell
is mitch mcconnell the most personally
pro-life man in america i don't know i
always sort of doubted it i don't know
what his personal views are all that
much but i do know
he held that seat open
when scalia died at the end of the obama
administration
mitch mcconnell held firm held that seat
open had he not held that seat open
we would not have this ruling today it's
a 5-4 ruling 6-3 to uphold the
mississippi law but it's 5-4 to overrule
roe v wade
5'4 to save hundreds of thousands of
babies per year
hundreds of thousands of babies per year
will be saved immediately as a direct
result of this ruling okay
mitch mcconnell deserves a lot of credit
for that and then of course
donald trump
donald trump you can't
you can't
give him too much credit for this
there's you can't over credit him for
this this guy because if if mcconnell
had held the seat and then trump had
lost
wouldn't matter
if mcconnell held the seat and trump had
gone squishy on the judges wouldn't
matter
but mcconnell held the seat trump did
what he said he would do he made a
promise to appoint a conservative
constitutionalist judge
vetted by the conservative legal
movement from that short list that he
had announced and he followed through
with that and it worked out and it gave
us this major victory
and the guy deserves so much credit
whatever you think about donald trump i
really like the guy i know some people
don't like him he's a polarizing figure
and they don't like the way he tweets
sometimes and they don't like some of
the things he did in office sure with
this ruling
donald trump has become no matter what
else he did in his presidency he has
become one of the greatest
and most significant presidents in
american history
that's done that's just
that's over now
his name is etched in the history books
as one of the greatest presidents
because of the importance of this ruling
today
there were children scheduled to die
in louisiana
in kentucky
in texas
in missouri
elsewhere as well
liberal journalists are tweeting this
out pulling their hair out of their head
they say oh no now abortion is legal is
illegal rather in these states
what does that mean
what that means is
that
a year from now 10 years from now 20 20
years from now there are going to be
people walking around this country
who are alive
because their mother was scheduled to go
in to an abortion mill today
june 24th 2022
and those kids were scheduled to be
killed
and because of this decision they were
not killed
and in some cases maybe
mothers will go elsewhere to have the
abortions but in a lot of cases they
won't they'll just have the babies
you've actually already seen this
happen the washington post ran a big
article on this
a young young lady who found out she was
pregnant but then it was right before an
abortion ban went into effect
and it was too late
and the girl gave birth to these twins
and the article i guess was supposed to
be
upset about this i guess it was supposed
to tug on our heartstrings and make us
think that
it would be better if she had killed the
babies but but i'm not so sure maybe
there was a secret conservative a secret
pro-lifer at the washington post because
it showed a picture of the babies and at
the very end the the young lady said
oh now
seeing my babies loving my babies oh my
gosh they're the greatest thing in the
world could you imagine it be so
terrible if i had killed them through
abortion those babies are alive because
of that law there will be lots and lots
of human beings people that you meet
people that you work with people that
run for office people in this country
who are alive because this happened
on this day
850 000 someone babies are killed every
year through abortion
this decision unfortunately doesn't
outlaw abortion nationwide but it is
going to deal a huge blow
to the abortion regime in america
and hundreds of thousands of babies per
year
will
live
because of this decision it's
it's astounding it's it's certainly
astounding enough that it would make me
want to
go out and do a second show today and it
makes me want to celebrate even more
and i i think we should all celebrate we
should give thanks to god and we should
pray
and we should hug our loved ones
we should we should really have a moment
of gratitude and joy our country got a
lot better today
i'm michael knowles this is michael
noelski